mes chers compatriotes quelques semaines
après les terribles attentats
terroristes qui ont endeuillé la france
je souhaite saluer les français qui ont
accompli leur devoir civique marquant
leur volonté d'offrir ainsi le visage
d'une démocratie vivante d'une
république déterminée et d'une france
fidèle elle même je veux remercier tous
nos candidats et nos militants qui ont
su trouver malgré les circonstances
l'énergie pour mener campagne en faveur
de l'alternance dans leur région après
la tragédie qui a frappé notre nation le
nécessaire rassemblement des français
face au terrorisme ne peut pas mettre
entre parenthèses le droit pour chacun
d'exprimer son point de vue sur la
situation de sa région et sur l'état de
la france
et le verdict des français ce soir est
clair c'est un message qu'il nous faut
tous entendre les français souhaitent
que la priorité pour tous les
responsables politiques soient que la
république ne recule plus est la trop
reculé et en particulier depuis bientôt
quatre années
ce message s'adresse d'abord à ceux qui
exercent les responsabilités à la tête
de l'état et de presque toutes les
régions de france
c'est un nouveau signe d'une profonde
aspiration des français
à voir les choses changer dans notre
pays ce message s'adresse à nous aussi
il nous faut entendre et comprendre
l'exaspération profondes des français
l'exaspération de tout ceux qui n'en
peuvent plus
de tous ceux qui travaillent dur et
qu'ils n'y arrivent plus de tout ce
qu'ils entreprennent et auquel on rend
la vie impossible de tous ceux qui se
sentent dépossédés du fruit de leur
travail qu'ils ont peur de perdre leur
emploi
peur de tout perdre
peur qu'on méprise leur identité et que
l'on change leur mode de vie ne pas
entendre cette exaspération serait
irresponsable ce soir toutes les
expressions de cette exaspération
doivent être considérées et bien sûr
respecter celle d'abord qu'ils sont
portés sur les candidats des
républicains et du centre mais aussi
celles qui ont fait le choix du front
national je veux dire à tous ceux qui
ont fait ce choix que nous entendons
leurs inquiétudes mais qu'ils
n'obtiendront aucune réponse d'un parti
dont les propositions aggraverait
dramatiquement la situation de la france
et créerait les conditions de dangereux
désordre dans leur région comme dans
notre pays
cette défiance qui est partout ronge
notre pays s'est également exprimée par
l'abstention dans des circonstances
aussi grave
je ne peux me résoudre à ce que plus de
20 millions de nos compatriotes ne vote
pas notamment tant de jeunes
pourtant chaque jour plus inquiets pour
leur avenir
il nous faut entendre ce découragement
civique
mais je veux dire aussi à tous ces
français qui se sont abstenus que leur
silence dans les urnes ne sera pas ne
sera jamais une réponse à leurs
inquiétudes et à leurs angoisses dans la
situation
particulièrement grave que connaît la
france
il est crucial que tous ceux qui veulent
l'alternance et qui ne se sont pas
exprimés aujourd'hui trouve dimanche
prochain le chemin des urnes à
l'occasion du deuxième tour
car dimanche prochain mes chers
compatriotes
chaque voix comptera il en va de
l'avenir de vos régions dans l'avenir de
notre pays
j'appelle tous les français à se
mobiliser en faveur de la seule
alternance crédible celle incarnée par
les candidats dits républicains et du
centre
c'est le choix de toutes celles et de
tous ceux qui ne veulent pas simplement
exprimé un rejet mais qui veulent
construire pour la région et pour la
france c'est le choix de toutes celles
et de tous ceux qui aspirent à un
changement réel et concret dans leur
quotidien et c'est le choix de toutes
celles et tous ceux qui sont décidés à
se mobiliser pour que la république ne
recule plus et c'est pour cette raison
que nous devons impérativement rester
fidèles à nos convictions
en refusant la tentation trop facile
après ce premier tour de jouer avec les
suffrages des français en choisissant je
ne sais quel arrangement tactique en
contradiction totale avec ce que nous
leur avons dit la seule attitude
républicaine qu'il convient d'adopter
pour nos candidats dans toutes les
régions sans exception c'est de
respecter les français en leur proposant
avec la constance de nos convictions
une alternance clair je proposerai
demain à notre bureau politique de
refuser toute fusion et tout retrait de
liste
la clarté et la constance sont les seuls
choix politique à la hauteur des
intérêts de vos régions
mes chers compatriotes et de la france
mes chers compatriotes j'ai conscience
de la responsabilité qui pèse sur notre
famille politique nous devons rester
lucides sur la lourdeur extrême de la
tâche qui nous attend mais jamais jamais
je ne me résigne rey devant un tel
niveau d'inquiétude de désarroi et de
colère
j'appelle tous ceux qui attendent
l'alternance à voter dimanche prochain
pour les candidats des républicains et
du centre je vous remercie
vive la république et vive la france